thirty million years ago in a distant
galaxy 30 million light years away to
black holes collided each black hole is
itself a significant disturbance in the
fabric of space and time when they
collide it creates an even greater
Ripple
that gets sent out at the speed of light
a ripple through the fabric of space and
time in the world of Technology a person
is born called Albert Einstein who
thinks about the fabric of space and
time comes up with the general theory of
relativity predicts the fact that such a
thing as ripples through the fabric of
space and time exists we would later
show that two black holes would be the
best example of a ripple through the
fabric of space and time meanwhile this
ripple continues to move Einstein
predicts we should be able to detect one
of these we don't have the technology
yet that would take another 80 and 90
years just to create the apparatus that
could detect it we build the apparatus
it holds a laser interferometric gravity
wave Observatory LIGO for short we turn
on the switch within days of turning on
the switch that wave washers across the
earth and we detect it
we detected something that was cast into
motion before we were human
Einstein not only predicted the
existence of gravity waves he came up
with the general theory of relativity he
also laid the foundation for the
invention of the laser and it has lasers
that were used to detect the gravity
waves that's badass
that's Einstein